by the time they were adults there was
unquenchable the harpes came to love the
tunnel they developed face to face
this is fiendish beyond belief
they make Jack the Ripper look like
nothing 13 o clock hey we're back again
you guys it's Tuesday and it's episode
112 yeah I know they're just zooming by
I know like I said the years just go on
well that Tommy guy that's what you
always sound like when you it's not like
there's anything you can do about it is
there isn't all right so episode 112
where actually I wanted to do another
true crime but since so many people had
been requesting that we do the Harpe
brothers America's first serial killers
as they are known I kind of wanted to
get around to doing them and also
because I want to do kind of a whole
historical true crime thing I also want
to talk about female serial killer Belle
Gunness also from the early days of
American history these killers I'm
actually surprised they're not better
known because they killed a [ __ ] ton
more people then and then a lot of the
modern fonts that you hear about and you
know they were pretty ruthless and like
I said so I kind of like the whole
historical aspect of that so we'll be
talking about that on this episode yeah
but before we do that let's do our
regular shoutouts yeah as I said my book
that faceless villain vol 2 is now out
in
print and ebook yeah and you can
actually see it on her author page yeah
like I said I had to link it yeah cuz I
forgot you know if you do Amazon you
have author central was or an author on
there and you have to like add it to my
library otherwise it doesn't do it
automatically I don't think or say with
Zazzle sazzle was acting up but you can
go explain Zazzle yeah a bunch of people
complain they're like hey we can't we
followed the link from your Zazzle storm
we can't see you know the like the
Atlanta Ripper shirt and some of the
demon child shirt and stuff like that
and I'm sitting there going what the
[ __ ] is the problem wait I can see them
you had to sign in to see them yeah it's
like some people said well if I signed
in with Facebook or with Google then I
could see them it's because and I only
just discovered this yesterday that
apparently you have to give your shirts
a G rating and Jamie grr yeah there's
ratings for the shirts so if you give
them anything higher than a G rating
then people have to be signed in to see
the CM so cuz I guess they don't want
little kids seeing them or whatever we
fixed there already G yeah so I rated
them all G so eventually you should be
able to see them all in a wait no four
of them to be yeah four of them are
still visible but if you don't want to
wait for them to become visible if you
sign in to using Facebook or Google I
believe you should be able to see all of
them there should be 16 things on there
yeah I was wondering what shirt sales
sucked because they were invisible yeah
that's like I I never would have thought
of that in a million years because I
kept you know marking the visibility I'm
like it's public and it's like I can see
it so why can't anybody else see them
we're gonna come up with some newer
designs - I want to black on with all
white you know have some dude maybe
running with Kukulcan or something with
a lid with a liquor motif and it lady
like some Mexican stuff on there and it
kind of copped out you know I mean
something that I would wear no I'm
riding my motorcycle some I wear you
know right where'd the club so something
that has to look a badass that's a
badass kind of like punk rocker
goth kind of looking yeah we'll come up
with some cool [ __ ] you know but yeah so
faceless villain - I've actually
recorded all but two chapters so I just
have two more chapters to record and
then I gotta edit it and start uploading
it so it should probably be like two two
and a half weeks and then that the
audiobook should be up as well
so if you are waiting for the audiobook
then it won't be that much longer that
you have to wait any reviews on your
boot piano notes reviews people yeah we
sold a lot I'm already and we just met
actually I was just on I don't think the
show I don't know if it's gonna be up
yet but I was just on conspiratorial
with Adam Sain podcast and I was talking
about a bunch of the cases that are in
this new book he's reading it in it
yeah yeah right and actually we're just
so we're just talking about like the
first half of the book because he's like
I didn't get all the way through it
because it's so long you know he's like
I didn't get all the way through before
I interviewed you so so let's just do
the first half and then we'll do the
other half like in a month or what do
you think in a matter what's he thinking
he like say yeah like there was a lot of
crimes in there that he didn't know
about even though he was really
interested in the ones that occurred
there were some that occurred in the
sixties in Nashville Tennessee like a
bunch of little girls and they he was
kind of interested in those because he
hadn't really heard that much about them
and he lived like right nearby where it
happened after Jenny did the show hit
they called me and to do like some bonus
material for patreon or his patrons and
everything I got I went off the hook I
went on board snagger it was he was
asking about his shitty movies yeah
Facebook group yeah I was talking about
t2 my problems with t2 leather daddy's a
little boys it's like I know what a
leather daddy is well yeah when little
boys on the back of the motorcycle we
know how Hollywood is nowadays man is
they tryin to send me
Cameron's trying to send us on the
ground subliminal messages but yeah so
anyway speaking of movies as I said
we've been using our AMC stoves a list
yeah subscription yeah it turned out
really we [ __ ] we've already made our
money back
burning it up and some burning to that
cuz we saw all three of our
movies last week the last one we saw was
the nun I love that app yes app is
really cool it's really easy to use yeah
and it's like yeah we saw the nun which
was in the contouring universe obviously
that was actually that actually was
pretty good we're the only ones in the
theater yeah we went inside you know
what
the Meg we saw the Meg I wouldn't pay to
see the Meg the meg is still in theaters
yeah still an AMC this me over 525
thought it was good they thought that
Hollywood thought that [ __ ] was gonna
bomb that's a Chinese movie yeah yeah
but there were like brothers it's such a
dumb movie it's not sophisticated it
probably won't make but about 40 million
in an opening week you know it just
shows you that Hollywood doesn't know
what it's doing man
the Chinese knew what a successful movie
should look like they called it the
Chinese called it they said we want a
conventional monster movie yeah I mean
it was I he's got muscles you know I
mean this is so basic and they ate it up
yeah it's still in it I mean it wasn't a
great movie but right it was
entertaining just fun yeah it was like
honestly I like the predator and the nun
a lot better but um yeah the Meg wasn't
bad now this week for this week coming
up like I said you have three movies a
week per person so we're gonna see what
are we seeing we're seeing the mission
we're seeing like a you see venom in
three and we'll probably see venom but
we're gonna go in the middle of the week
cuz I don't want to go at night when
there's like 50 bajillion yeah I like
the a-list thing you know you can go on
you can go during the day you know and
you can see off-brand movies it doesn't
really cost any extra you can't watch 12
movies a month really there's not enough
enough starting it's like we've have to
go see someone twice or something don't
feel like this one because some of those
I have no interest in yeah and it's
pretty nice program I mean it says it's
it's as good as shutter shutter was a
real good deal too five dollars a month
and that's it man were abusing the [ __ ]
out of that burnin up shot we watch like
four movies last night yeah on the Xbox
on my xbox yeah it was like well it was
Friday night we were drinking like
eating subpoenas and yeah
big thing of peanuts would what do we
watch me watch now howling which we're
probably gonna do a review of Black
Sabbath Boris Karloff we also watched
zombie zombie well part of it you don't
blue she a fool true one cuz I haven't
seen that for many years we probably do
a review on that too and Exorcist three
which was actual oh it's I remembered
that being really good but I'm like [ __ ]
man that movie was creepy as [ __ ] I
forgot about pretty cool yeah George see
Scott was in that [ __ ] it's all classy
and everything just like yeah I really
like that movie a lot so yeah shudders a
really also a really good value so I
think that's about it um as usual if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
which I'll tell you later
or you can go to our blog and go to the
PayPal link in the little sidebar there
if you'd like to give a one-time
donation also time is running out if you
would like your Halloween stories
whether horror fiction or whether true
paranormal or whatever just long as it's
a scary story if you would like that
read on our Halloween spooktacular
special then you need to email me that
[ __ ] at grave cake at gmail.com you have
maybe a week or two to send it to
because we're actually gonna record it a
little bit early you know so I can get
everybody cuz we might have some guests
on the show and we're trying to like
coordinate when people can come we're
gonna have a little Halloween yeah and
stuff like that so yeah we're gonna
we're gonna read the stories and we're
gonna like have you know our friends
over for Halloween and stuff like that
so um if you would like them read then
go ahead and email them to me and also
if you're one of our $20 and up patrons
and you haven't sent me your shirt and
the size you want and stuff like that
then you probably need to do that same
because I'm gonna start ordering the
shirts over the next few months because
like I said we wanted to order them like
a few at a time just yeah so what's like
the expense we got new lighting yeah
well we just whit's the same lighting we
just moved it that way we don't look
like we're a million years old oh yeah I
wanted a beautiful soft glue well we had
been having the light behind us and I'm
just like man I look like a hag I don't
really look like a hag I don't think
lines in your face look like a million
miles deep
put the light over here we need you in
front of us that's what I'm telling you
in front man behind you yes not good
unless you just wanted to go to little
silhouette and so no one can see my face
that my work do all right so let's start
out I'm not gonna do a news story since
we're doing two different cases so we're
just gonna do I'll probably do the Hart
brothers first and then we'll take a
break and then I'll talk about Belle
Gunness after the break yeah I don't
know yeah these cases so you know I'm
just along for the ride
what else is new oh I don't I don't know
anything they can't make silly comedy
kind of like the comedic relief so as I
said they're generally known as the
Harpe brothers even though they're not
sure if they actually were brothers they
might have been cousins right so these
two guys have the distinction of being
the u.s. is first known serial killers
their names were mkhaya harp and Wiley
Harpe mchao is known as big harp and
Wiley was known as little harp because
one was much larger rather than the
other one obviously now they're either
like I said this was a very long time
ago this was the late 1700s damn that
long yes
so sources differ they were either born
in Scotland and emigrated to the United
States with their families you know when
they were children or they were born
here like shortly after their families
moved here but they were of Scottish
descent like many of Scottish descent
from the area where they came from they
were you know in the whole American
Revolution type thing leading up to that
they were loyalists they were loyal to
the British crown
that explains it which yeah which kind
of made them I meet their neighbors I
like them so much so the story goes so
there is some there has been some
speculation and like I said a lot of
Legends have grown up about these two
guys so they're not sure entirely when
they're not really entirely sure how
many people they killed it was a lot but
they also are not really sure like what
like why they did what they did we have
been a political motive is where yeah
well they're just saying that because
their family was kind of reportedly
targeted by you know American colonists
American you know Patriots as they
called them who were you know anti
British then that might have contributed
to their hatred towards problems later
on where they pretty much that they're
serial killers in the sense that they
killed dozens of people but the
interesting thing about it is that they
didn't have a particular victim profile
they'd pretty much just kill any
[ __ ] that got in their way or
pissed them off they had they seemed to
have no conscience no scruples no
nothing you know and you're you're
talking about the late 1700s in the
American frontier
you know there's highwaymen there were
pirates
there were various other things where
people just kill you and take your [ __ ]
and it wasn't really that big of a deal
but these two are kind of a cut above
because they seem to enjoy it they
didn't always do it for a particular
motive of like we're I'm just gonna take
your stuff they did but that wasn't the
only reason it seemed like they actually
really liked it and plus they did a lot
of like mutilations and stuff that we're
not necessary hmm so that's why they
call them America's first serial killers
so they think that like I said they came
from they came from Scotland now they at
some point they're not real sure what
years they were born they think Micaiah
well who was big Harpe was born sometime
before 1768 and wily little Harpe was
born sometime before 1770 but they're
not entirely sure now in about 1775 they
were actually living in North Carolina
their families had emigrated to North
Carolina in 1775 they went to Virginia
and they were going to get work as
overseers on a slave plantation so they
kind of what they did they got in with
these other loyalist groups or irregular
they also called them yeah and by some
accounts joined a rape gang like what
you do
and regulars that was basically
mercenaries yeah all right so as a port
of the crown yeah so they joined this
group that would just basically go
around raping and pillaging attacking
colonists burning down their stuff
taking their [ __ ] raping their women
that type of stuff yeah so that's kind
of where these two guys were at yeah in
other words if there was a town that
they thought were gonna be disloyal to
the crown they'd send these guys in here
to punish from bottom basically the
Hessians were doing the same thing yeah
similar type of allegation yeah so in
about this time there are speculations
that little Harpe attempted to rape a
girl in North Carolina who and then he
was shot by a man named Captain James
Wood but he was just wounded he didn't
die
unfortunately so then the next that they
know of them cuz like I said they kind
of moved around and they you know
there's stretches where they don't
really know where they were in 1780 they
actually joined with regular the regular
British army they actually were not paid
they didn't have uniforms or anything
like that but like you said they were
mercenaries so they kind of had to steal
all their own supplies and whatnot so
they joined with some troops some
British troops and they were in a bunch
of battles around the North and South
Carolina borders then about a year after
that they joined in with a renegade
group of Cherokee who were actually
fighting with the British these were the
Chickamauga Cherokee Indians and so they
so they all of those same kind of thing
these Indians and the harpes would go
around raiding settlements and
everything now at this stage they decide
they're going to take revenge on Captain
wood the guy that shot little Harpe
after their rape so they kidnapped his
daughter who was named Susan and then
they kidnapped this other woman named
Maria Davidson and they made them become
their wives you know what I mean both of
them yeah by all accounts they shared
these two women so yeah I don't know
like in
later speculation is kind of like how
much complicity do these women have with
these guys crimes everything because
they kind of traveled with him for a
very long time but you know I don't know
the fact that they were kidnapped and
the be beginning I'm kind of thinking
you know whatever they might well they
were supposedly kidnapped don't yeah the
story that they gave yeah like I said I
don't know it was so then during this
time so the two of them and the women
and then there were four other guys who
they don't know who they were but they
were just like other gang members so
then they start heading toward Tennessee
now while they're along this trip
there's this guy and his name is Moses
Doss and he was actually worried about
the safety of the women are like what
was going on with them and he apparently
foolishly
said something about it like hey why
don't you let them go or why you so mean
to them or something along those lines
so the harpes then killed him as they
would do you know subsequently so then
right now I'm at much I must say at this
point this is not normal mercenary
behavior you know that's why this [ __ ]
stuck out yeah yeah that's why I do this
regular like I said these guys were not
it wasn't a kind of thing where we just
killed people for supplies or whatever
because it was a lot of people doing
that like I said there was pirates it
was all kind of stuff where they were
just killing people because they wanted
their stuff these two would just kill
people for the hell of it yes
mercenaries are just professional
soldiers yes and the United States Army
is a professional army seat it and
there's non-us citizens in the army so
you know when I was in I was basically
serving with mercenaries some of the
guys from Ireland guys from Mexico they
weren't even US citizens yeah they were
just working for a paycheck and they had
permission to be in there they get
citizenship later on yeah that kind
stuff but yeah so like I said these two
are not right yeah well not normal these
guys were just it almost sounds like
this is something having to do with some
of the Indian wars because this kind of
[ __ ] was going on with you like you said
irregular x' yeah personal soldiers
being hired to you know hired by certain
empires sometimes Indians are hired by
certain Empire
to get certain things done because it
was just so hard to get a European army
into the New World you know yeah because
you know the causeway the long way and
the cause ocean so you recruit and hire
guys there on site you know I mean but
this is weird this is this is a weird
time you know this is almost like a
post-apocalyptic world do you know that
this is going on and in forests with no
central government and and competing
governments in the same territory and
then tribes yeah it's a you know so this
is uh you know there was a lot of Mad
Max yeah there was a lot of lawlessness
yeah these two guys yes full advantage
I'm actually surprised that more people
didn't but the fact that these two and
as I'll say later on even some like
mercenaries and pirates and stuff like
that were like oh whoa okay you guys
yeah too much Jim yeah it was so it was
that you you know they were bad if
people were hunting that methylated
during this baby yeah
so after they killed Moses dose then
they went to there was this Cherokee
Chickamauga village called Nicky Jack
it's kind of near where Chattanooga is
today in Tennessee and they lived in
this village for about twelve or
thirteen years during this period the
two wives actually got pregnant twice I
don't know if that's twice each or once
each I'm not really sure that it's not
real clear reportedly all of these
children were killed by their fathers
because they'd kill babies do they
didn't give it they didn't give a single
[ __ ] late term abortion yeah yeah I
don't know how old the children were
going to kill them didn't have time for
that I guess not yeah um okay so 1781
the British surrender at Yorktown the
Chickamauga and another band of
Cherokees that were kind of like
breakaway and there you know loyal to
the British crown still there cannot
kind of fight in the colonists and
everything like that so the harpes
decided to throw in their lot with them
and also you know kept fighting against
the colonists they were actually in the
Battle of blue licks in Kentucky that
was in August 1782 and a bunch of other
little battles around that time
so now in 1794 in autumn the colonists
were actually going to attack this
village in nikich AK and fight with the
Indians the loyalist Indians
so the somehow the Hart brothers or
cousins or whatever big and little Harpe
they found out about this and got the
[ __ ] out of Dodge uh meanwhile the
colonists wiped out the village so the
next that they know of big and little
Harpe was in this other camp that wasn't
too far away but they stayed there about
nine months and then they would go
around to like local bills like pillage
them and like take all their [ __ ] and
everything like that
next they know of them was in 1797 and
they were living in
beavers Creek like on the shores of
beavers Creek like in this little cabin
that was near present-day Knoxville and
they still had the two wives like I said
that had been their pregnant a lot of
times like during this whole thing and
like I said they shared both of them but
at this point little Harpe marries
another woman this is a third woman and
her name is Sara rice and there is
record of that so they were officially
married the other two like I said not so
much they were just like basically
slaves yeah essentially their size but
this woman he little Harpe did actually
marry and she was the daughter of a
minister so she essentially just started
traveling around with them just look the
other ones now they had killed people
prior to this obviously but the real
spree of murder did not really start
until 1798 and it started in Tennessee
they killed two guys there then they
went to Kentucky and killed two more men
who were just traveling along the road
killed him and took their [ __ ] the thing
that they would do like I said they
weren't just shooting people and taking
their stuff they were killing them and
then they were cutting them open filling
their abdominal cavities with stones and
leaving them in a creek like for people
to find like really gruesome like
mutilation were they doing that to them
while they were alive oh no I'm not
really sure maybe it sounds like
thing they would do you know what I mean
it almost sounds like they had been in
contact with some of those some of the
more aggressive Indian tribes yeah yeah
Indians life support or two they learned
it they evidently picked it up from the
Spanish and some of those Indian tribes
would do weird things like you know Flay
you alive using sharpen two seashells
bury you alive in ant mounds and watch
you get picked apart you know that kind
of stuff well you know there isn't any
law and order you have to you know
sometimes you have to drop your nuts
using terror don't come in here or we do
this to you
that's essentially what the issue we're
doing although I'm not sure like I said
they didn't really seem to have an end
game in particular um they were
opportunists they would kill people and
take their stuff if they wanted it but
they did seem to like to kill people
like I said just for the fun of it it's
like well I kind of already have an idea
who it is you deal it with them you
don't know how much you have left but I
can give you my opinion when you're done
I pretty much made I pretty much had
kind of figured it out in my mind who
these guys are okay so the next guy they
killed was a guy named John Lanford he
was actually traveling on the road from
Virginia to to Kentucky now at this
stage there was an innkeeper who
suspected that big and little Harpe were
responsible for this guy's murder so he
gets the law around to check these two
guys out now for a while the authorities
did capture them and put them in jail in
Danville Kentucky but they got out now
all three of the women that were with
them were pregnant at the time so they
left them in the jail because you know
they they were very heavily pregnant and
they had two women to prison two women -
yes because they were with them so they
figured erode it cause it um yeah
so the the pregnant women were left
behind they actually as far as I know
they all gave birth while they were
still in custody the children were about
two months apart each okay so big and
little Harpe escaped then they send a
posse after them now evidently the son
of a guy that was helping the lawmen
find the two guys he was also later
found dead in Moodle
so the harpes had killed him in revenge
for this guy helping them out he's like
I'm gonna kill your son and me delete
him so for a while they didn't know
where they were the Governor of Kentucky
put a $300 reward on each of their heads
which was a quite a bit of money back
then obviously so while they're fleeing
north the brothers killed two more men
a guy named Edmonton and a guy named
stump then they were at the they came
upon a camp on the banks of the saline
River and there was like three guys just
like in a little encampment there just
minding their own business and of course
the harpes killed all of them all so
they then went to southern Illinois this
place called cave in the rock cave in
the rock was actually a well known was
was the well-known base of a river
pirate named Samuel Mason and he had a
gang and him and his little pirates what
they would do they would be like these
flat boats you know that all these
supplies on them and they would be going
down the Ohio River and you know the
Pirates would stop them and just kill
everybody and take all their [ __ ]
so the harpes are hanging out with this
pirate gang now at this stage like I
said this is a pirate gang and Samuel
Mason is a very very well known River
pirate they did some horrible things
even they when the harpes started doing
their thing they were just like yo Bros
is like that know just why because you
know what the harpes would like to do
sometimes they would get people they
would take them up to the top of the
rock because it's like this little cave
it's like a natural formation it's like
this big rock at the top with like a
river on the bottom they would take him
up to the top of the rock they would
strip all their clothes off then they
would tie them to a horse or put them on
a horse so they couldn't get off they
would blindfold the horse and then make
the horse run off the cliff so they
liked that like I said they enjoyed
torture they enjoyed tormenting people
yeah and like I said even the Pirates
were just like this that's not cool it's
like why go to all that trouble real I
suppose you know what I mean so for the
most part you know
people say pirate you thinking these
wild outlaws that's not really the case
you had to have a license to be a pirate
yeah get that I don't know if these
River Pirates had a license but usually
you were working in the employment of
one of the Empire's British Empire
Spanish Empire they give you a license
to go out there do it yeah now of course
whatever Empire you were stealing from
they consider you a criminal but the
people who had employed you considered
you to be a contractor yeah you know
you're like they got stuff right it kind
of had certain rules that they were
supposed to follow yeah but yeah I'm not
about the river pirates though I don't
know if these guys were working for
anybody or if they were just bandits
over every Lance right yeah cuz there's
a difference between being a licensed
you know a licensed pirate a privateer
privateer and somebody who's just a
bandit yeah yeah stealing for themselves
I have a feeling these guys were just
kind of winging it because the fireman
had Dave like you do a true privateer
pirate had to give you know certain
portion of his of the booty to the
empire that he was working for you but
yeah so this whole [ __ ] with they were
they were just like throw people off
cliffs and they thought it was hilarious
so even then the pirates were like you
know you guys just you just go away we
just can't deal with this anymore so the
Pirates kick them out so them and the
women they then go to Eastern Tennessee
this was like in summer of 1798 now they
know that they killed three more people
there was a farmer and named Bradbury
and another guy named Hardin and then it
was like a young boy like a teenage boy
I think he was 13 his name was a coffee
then they found another body of a guy
named William Ballard he had been just
like the other guy had been disemboweled
had rocks put in his abdominal cavity
and then thrown in a river I wonder why
they're doing that
like I said they liked it they seemed
like they liked it that was you wanted
there that was like their signature he
disemboweled somebody it killed him
pretty quick yeah almost almost makes me
think that maybe they were just trying
to wait wait the body down they were but
it seems like there's easier ways to do
that
taking wires she couldn't wrap them in
chicken wire and yeah I don't know why
it's just maybe that's not true maybe I
have something somebody made up about
him I don't know because that does seem
to be something that happened more than
ones like more than one victim was found
that way rocks in their abdomen yes yeah
like they were cut open and all their
guts were taken out they also killed
another guy named James brothel whose
throat was slashed
they also found another man named John
Tully who was murdered and then in
south-central Kentucky there's a guy
named John graves and he had a teenage
son they both had their heads axed in
then the big and little Harpe also
killed a little girl then they killed a
teenage boy that was a slave then they
killed an entire family that was
sleeping in a camp just because then
this is nice
so then the harpes are all camping with
the women and the children because they
did travel with the three women and
their attendant children apparently I
don't know if it was big Harpe stud or
little harpes daughter but she was like
an infant little girl and she was crying
and big Harpe got annoyed and picked up
the baby by her feet and smashed her
against a tree yeah
and killed her so probably his own
daughter yeah it was yeah that's first
you know and well it was either his
daughter it was the other guy's daughter
so they were all related the psychos
yeah then they found another guy this
was the same month that this happened
there was a guy named trow bridge and he
was also found disemboweled in highland
creek same kind of deal and then the
harpes next turn up at this house of a
family called the steagle z-- I guess
they ran an inn and the harps were
staying there now while they were
staying there because they apparently
just couldn't help themselves
there was another guest staying with the
steagle family his name was Major
William love and the harpes killed him
as well they also killed mrs. steagald
four month old baby boy because he was
crying they slit his throat
obviously mrs. steagle was not too happy
about that and started screaming so they
killed her as well so okay at this point
like I said there's rewards on these two
guys heads
there's posses chasing
I'm all over the place right because
they're just leaving a trail of dead
yeah as they go across the states and
like I said it's just [ __ ] up [ __ ]
they're not stealing so I mean they are
but it's not doesn't seem to be the main
reason it seems like just kind of like
bloodlust you know what I mean they just
can't help themselves
so yeah the posses are coming after them
now the the guy whose house they were
staying in when he killed the baby and
the what and the wife
Moses steagle that was obviously his
wife and baby so he was part of one of
the posses that was that was coming
after them so they're chasing them so
the harpes they were actually planning
to kill this other settler whose name
was George Smith but in August of 1799
the posse finally caught up with the
harpes now big Harpe got shot in the leg
and in the back so he was wounded so the
posse like swarms them and they get on
top of him now he's dying so they say so
he confesses to 20 murders although they
think there's a lot more than that he
confesses to 20 he says the only one he
feels bad about is his own daughter
Brooke did he smashed her head against a
tree so hmm
little late for that now buddy yeah but
um yeah but this is hardcore
so Moses steagle you know the harpes had
killed his wife and baby Moses steagle
slowly saws off big harpes head while
he's still alive and then takes big
harps head they either put it sources
different they either put it on a pole
or in a tree so everyone could see it so
they can say this is what happens to
outlaws you know so they left his head
there so they're I don't understand
Saudis that often yeah passion you know
I mean God killed a bunch of women and
children so they make him suffer
hold him down for Christ's sake yeah I
don't blame him not a bit
it's an American version of the
over-braking somebody on the wheel
that's the frontier version CPAs hand me
that song yes
now evidently if any of you live in
Kentucky and can still tell me I don't
know if the place is still called this
but the crossroads where they displayed
the head was for many years known as
harps head row yeah I don't know if it
still happened either but like I said
we're gonna be good so little harp yeah
that's what I mean see you don't even
know you don't know the facts you're
already coming up with [ __ ] okay so
little harp got away and he actually
went back to Illinois to the cave in the
rock and rejoined Samuel Mason the other
the river pirates now he actually lived
with them they think for about four
years he was going under and aeleus they
think it was John Seddon or John Sutton
so he was trying to hide out now this is
where he got into trouble so evidently
the authorities wanted also wanted
Samuel Mesa in the river pirate so there
was a big reward to bring the head of
Samuel Mason to the authorities so
little harp goes catching so he so him
and this other guy named geo somebody
killed Samuel Mason the river pirate and
sawed his head off and brought it to the
authorities like a dumbass and so the
authorities were like hey that's little
harp yeah so yeah so they didn't fall
for it no yeah so him and the other
pirate they were arrested because
they're like we know who you [ __ ] are
right nice you just like you guys are
idiots like you know they're criminals
it's like how can smart can they be so
ya know now they did escape from custody
but they recaptured them shortly
afterward and they were arrested they
were convicted they were sentenced to
hang
so in January of 1804 both the pirate
James May and little Harpe were executed
their heads were also cut off and placed
on stakes along the Natchez Trace Road
in order to as a warning to the others
American justice yeah don't do that oh
so okay so how many people did they kill
ok confirmed as far as I
no 39 but they think that it was more
than 50 because there were a whole lot
of victims that are like not accounted
for and they know the harps were in that
area or they you know it was a similar
MO or something like that but they know
they killed at least 39 probably more
than 50 men women children they did not
discriminate if you just got in their
way or you annoyed them or pretty much
any other reason or they just had a
crack across their ass that day then
they would just kill you and that would
be the end of it
these are not stereotypical serial
killers they are not about serial
killers per se these are just mass
murderers yeah I mean you know like I
said it didn't have a sexual motive or
anything like that there theorist there
basically Wild West outlaws their early
prototypes of Wild West outlaws and
they're just doing what they saw what
they saw in some of these in the
revolution and I guess you could say
probably like enduring Indian Wars you
bright glass some classify them as
Indian Wars yeah that was the kind of
stuff but they were just doing it
against their own people although they
may have not considered these Americans
these other white people their own
people they might have considered
traitors to traitors and yeah they had
been considered them they may have
considered themselves it to be at war
with them I feel like there might have
been an aspect of that like I said it
was a long time ago and they're not
entirely sure but they think that
they're loyalists sympathies like that
to the to the British crown might have
because the other the American colonists
were so against them that that might
have had something to do I could
guarantee you one thing all right I can
tell you these guys were dumb they were
dumb and they were mean yeah you know so
you know being dumb and mean and having
a lot of violence in your background and
a lot of battle experience especially
seeing a lot of atrocities and kind of
warped the mind you know I mean kind of
warped their view of what normal is you
know I'm sure you're sure they you know
I'm sure they'd already seen a lot of
little dead kids yeah it didn't bother
them so well even kids yeah
psychos well here's a deal those were
kids that were that came out of their
slaves
so they probably
didn't have a connection with him
emotionally you know doesn't Siri
doesn't seem like they had a connection
with anyone personally no sounds like
they were Psychopaths yeah and I would
also probably say that not only were
they cyclists they were probably pretty
dumb you're probably talking about guys
with AD IQs they don't like the sharpest
knives now what would what would make
you think that just because you were on
a frontier zone that you you would get
away with that for very long
well that's the Dutch thing even back
then you didn't yeah up on you new hunt
you down I mean it took a long time but
it's like hey I'm gonna go stand in and
oh by the way everyone's pissing me off
so I'm just gonna kill them all yeah
how did you do that history shows all
right hide it history the American
history is shown over and over again in
that period all we happen to the end to
the 1900s you could kill an occasional
person and get away with it yeah of
course but if you kill lots of people
especially whole families you know with
with regularity your ass is grass well
yeah they're tremonti they're gonna find
your ass a lot of that a lot of these a
lot of the reasons why people did get
away with the murders that they did back
in those days it was victims of
victimology yeah they were killing
people that were not popular yeah and
also they weren't killing people in very
large numbers yeah and you know limited
limited ability of law enforcement and
they would just evade capture a evade
detection to you know but doing what
they're doing wiping out whole ends and
whole families you become an enemy of
humanity they hunt you down yeah
because think of all the people that you
were making mad right yeah that you're
leaving alive like innocent people is is
not in your survival interests yeah
that's what I mean that's why I think
these guys actually shade more toward
serial killer because they killed people
for no reason why did they were dumb
dumb and cruel and yeah yeah like let's
just kill little kids let's kill
innocent women and then it's like oh now
you get all the husbands and brothers
and fathers and people like coming after
you I think they were dumb and they
wanted to steal and they thought well we
can kill them we can get away with it
yeah you know everybody else is killing
it started piling up they'll just think
the Indians did they could show anywhere
without killing yeah right it's like
like I said let me help themselves so
now the interesting thing about the
three women that were left behind
now at some stage like I said they were
actually in jail and they did stand
trial for some of the murders like as
accomplices but because they were all
pregnant or they you know they all had
their babies or whatever the jury
actually took pity on them and they were
released now by all accounts after the
harpes
died they actually kind of you know
spread out and they actually went on to
live perfectly normal acceptable eyes
mr. Murray married you know and lived
somewhere else so they didn't you know
they didn't have like an outlaw
lifestyle or anything like that they
respectable women at least two of them
were captives yes you know they know I
mean the Third Way went along with it
but they had to there was no choice I
mean that's what I mean why kill their
own kids that's what I mean what are you
gonna do in some ways it's like I don't
know how much I can blame those
particularly back then because women
were just like cattle man it's like
nobody gave a [ __ ] what they wanted or
anything like that so it's like well
weird year just coming along with us and
and when they see what these guys are
doing yeah it's like what the [ __ ] are
they gonna do they don't have any money
they don't have anywhere to go it's like
what are they gonna do they're gonna
leave and it's like probably get killed
too although coming out and saying
during that period that women in the new
world were worthless in like cattle and
not really not well these ones were yeah
those were I mean what's funny is that
when the women of power okay that's what
if you want to put weren't the ones you
would actually expect to have power
really the ones who had all the money in
the power and all the freedom were some
kind of what they call sport and gal
well is the brothel Madam's yeah like
that they call him a star it was a
high-class shame in Europe yeah
high-class prostitute she didn't have to
get married there were no rules on her
she was very popular had a lot of money
yeah do what you want me [ __ ] Dunham oh
yeah didn't do it ever they want and
they can do what they want to be random
parlors yeah they weren't under the same
stress yeah yeah and they had protection
a law enforcement because all the cops
and all the guys loved them yeah so they
could do what they wanted same kind of
thing but like I said these were the
Geisha of the Americans these women were
not in that situation by any stretch of
the imagination like I said two of them
were apparently kidnapped the other one
did marry the guy but I don't know how
much she knew about him or if he coerced
her into it who knows but like I said
after the harpes died they apparently
went
lived completely normal lives they
remarried and you know by all accounts
were totally fine so you know other than
that like I said this it's really weird
because I mean obviously they don't
teach you about the harps in American
history in school and I had actually
never really heard of them until a bunch
of people recommended this topic so
thank you for recommending it because
this is something I had never known
about and like I said it's really
interesting because these dudes killed
at least 39 people probably more I mean
you know considering how long they were
on the run it must have been more than
that
and we still remember Jack the Ripper
who killed five people that they know of
it you know we still remember other
serial killers that killed you know a
dozen but that's a lot that's bad but
these two bobbies they were like a mini
baby catastrophe yeah and like babies
and stuff like picking him up and
throwing as a [ __ ] man that's like not
even human Jesus I guarantee you never
saying oh boy I'm gonna take that [ __ ]
we'll kill them all okay yeah they'll
say the Indians did it they were like
that yeah and like I said a lot of
legend has kind of grown up around these
two if you see like the devil and Daniel
Webster which they which is a play and
then it was a movie and stuff there are
two characters in there that are based
on the harps the robber bridegroom which
looks like a musical or a play that also
has a couple characters based on them so
there is there have been some stuff in
pop culture that are based on these two
guys but as atrocious as their
activities were I'm just surprised that
they're not better a noun I mean guys
look it's like I was a long time ago
yeah like I'm super into true crime and
stuff and I'm really into Victorian
crime also but for some reason I didn't
really I kind of heard of them but I
didn't really know anything about them
or who they were anything like that so
thank you for recommending that these
several people that recommended it so I
guess we're going to let's see what
we're doing on time okay [ __ ] where are
you okay so we're gonna take a break
right now when we come back we will talk
about yet another serial killer female
serial killer not many of those and this
is also from kind of the early days of
history although about a century later
after the heart brothers this is the
infamous Belle Gunness so we're gonna
take a break right now and
in just a few minutes
[Music]
I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day at this house and will
continue to be buddy Ginny's got some
new shirt designs up four of them really
good ones to Atlanta Ripper who put
Bella in the which out the HH Holmes
murder castle and of course demon child
cuz man said he could these are updated
designs I think they look really cool
Jenny did a great job
bottom where they found making Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah it
really good they're very high quality
shirts Jenny and I we're sure our own
shirts at certain times when we're
trying to put a spotlight on ourselves
and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them mix in the description WWL
comm at 13 o'clock yes ago check out our
store at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got
these four cool new t-shirt designs plus
all our old ones if you'd rather get one
of the old ones but these ones are
awesome and you should check them out
they're also available in women's cotton
they look really cute JD's got some so
thank you go check them out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we're back we're back yeah now
we are talking about yet another
historical serial killer and we had to
get a new drink we had to get well you
did I had I still I still had mine this
is this is vodka
it's vodka with cherry and passion fruit
yeah mine's mojito yeah you had to make
a mojito we're out of juice yeah some
people have asked us to identify the
cocktail that's it like I said if we
knew more cocktail recipes we could do
like a theme for you but it's like you
know that would that would necessitate
like buying tons well I gave out the
recipe to my favorite drink on on Tom's
shitty movies yeah it's called a kugel
Khan yeah yeah one part pineapple juice
yes one part what's the name of it I've
been drinking already now okay one part
pineapple what's that other drink what's
that of the juice guava guava there you
go yeah in some countries called [ __ ]
ABBA
all right so one part pineapple one part
guava one part tequila of your choice
over ice and that is a cool cool car
yeah and boy put a hurtin on you they're
good though yeah he's just he's gonna
just start talking not drink purely
American Central American South Amer
that's a new world drink for you guys
over there and you in Europe you guys
can hook that up make that on your own
you might have to add a little bit of
simple syrup maybe a little bit of lemon
to get the sweet and sour right
depending on the source of the juice you
do it to taste yeah like I said Minds
easy mine's just one part vodka two
parts Carey and passion fruit juice yeah
from well it's delicious actually
yeah doesn't even taste like there's
alcohol in it but over there is yeah yes
all right so now we're doing we're
covering a topic which I even wanted to
do a long time cuz I'm super fascinated
by female
killers because like I said there's not
that and they do tend to have different
motivations as this woman does as well
now this woman is
I guess she's kind of well-known but not
as well-known as you would think cuz
like I said she has quite a high body
count by some estimates anywhere between
25 and 40 victims they're not entirely
sure um I I feel like and I'm gonna say
this right like right at the outset
female serial killers in general not all
of them obviously um female serial
killers tend to kill in a more practical
manner for practical reasons as this
woman did they don't get all fancy yeah
well they don't seem to I'm not saying
they don't enjoy it but they don't seem
to sexually get off on it they just seem
to do it as a means to an end they're
like this person is just in the way so
I'm just gonna bump them off a lot of
the male ones are doing it kind of like
to magnify their power yeah the people
suffer right like I said I feel like
women are usually doing it for either
financial reasons or to get rid of
someone who's kind of get in their way
or whatever or you know like I said for
practical reasons or to feed some kind
of weird emotional you know because you
know you have those nurses that like
poison all those people so they can feel
like they're saving munchausen people
yeah like that kind of thing
so it seems like those are the main
things now Belle Gunness otherwise known
as hells bells or the lady Bluebeard she
also known as that too
gotta put some ac/dc she was actually
originally she was born in Norway her
son she was like born on a farm there
and her father was a stonemason now
evidently I'm not sure they think she
was born around 1859 not entirely sure
but there is a story I'm not sure if
this is true or not I don't know someone
just invented this like to kind of
justify like her crimes later on or like
explain them not justify them and
explain them there's a story that in her
early years I guess in her like late
teenage years
evidently she was still in Norway this
was prior to her coming to the United
States she went to a country dance in
the town where she was from and she was
pregnant while she was at this day
this man kicked her in the stomach and
made her have a miscarriage damn and
because the guy was wealthy and she was
poor he kind of got away with it now the
story goes that that kind of gave her a
lifelong hatred of men so and did that
really happen I don't know it sounds
like a legend it's unverified but
several of her biographers have repeated
this story so I don't know if it's true
or not but that's how the story goes
just sounds like a legend doing it yeah
it might be like I said somebody trying
to explain like why she did later on so
the interesting thing too and that's
actually not the end of the story but
apparently the guy that kicked her in
the stomach not long after this happened
mysteriously died of stomach cancer very
young okay
and some people think that she poisoned
his ass so like I said you're not real
sure just off the top of my hand man I
must say that's a legend it's probably
American legend the early pulp you know
or early pulp newspapers would have made
up well you know okay let's roll with
that yes roll like I said it could have
happened I'm not gonna happen but it's
not confirmed but it's something that
comes out so at any rate now her one of
her sisters named Nellie Larson had
already emigrated to the United States a
little while before so in 1881 Belle
Gunness who was actually she was born
and I know I'm gonna pronounce this
wrong sorry people from Norway she was
actually born Brunhilde Paul's daughter
store sit that was her birth name but
when she went to the United States in
1881 she decided to take a more
Americanized kind of name she actually
first when she got there she worked as a
servant for a little while she arrived
in 1881 and worked as a servant for
about three years then she meets this
guy named Mads Sorenson in Chicago and
they got married and then they opened up
like a candy store now evidently the
candy store even from the beginning was
not financially doing very well so it
was only open for about a year and then
it mysteriously burned down you know how
that goes
insurance wires exactly I was that's
what I was waiting for you to say wires
I don't know those insurance gas pipes
got cross yes that's probably exactly
what so with the proceeds from the
insurance they actually bought a house
now there has been some debate over
whether her and Mads had any children
most research say they did that they had
four they were named Caroline Axl Myrtle
and Lucy now Caroline and Axl both died
in infancy from what they termed back
then acute colitis damn which that means
[ __ ] and your brains out pretty much it
yeah it's diarrhea nausea that type of
stuff now some people have pointed out
in light of Bell's later activities that
she may have poisoned these two children
because the symptoms of colitis are very
similar to like strychnine poisoning
arsenic poisoning that type of stuff so
the two children died in infancy yeah
and it's funny that two of them came
down with colitis yeah that does seem a
little doesn't it yeah yeah right so and
another thing pointing to her
involvement was that both of these kid
who were babies essentially both had
life insurance policies yeah she's kind
which yeah do you try to ensure a baby
hmm I wonder why I was like she's trying
to get rid of her financial liabilities
and they make a few bucks yeah that's
pretty much exactly what it sounds like
yeah
so those two babies very very late term
abortion again yeah yeah so the
insurance companies paid out on those
two now okay so then there was in the
1900 census Belle Gunness comes up on
the census records and at that point it
shows that two of her children were
deceased and that two of them Myrtle was
still alive she was three and then she
had one named Lucy who was one at this
stage this is 1900 also there is a
ten-year-old girl apparently an adopted
daughter living in the house
with Belle and mad Sorensen this girl is
alternately known as either Morgan couch
or Jenny Olsen she's more commonly known
as Jenny Olsen
so she was apparently an adopted
daughter she was living with them in
1900 now later on that year MADD
Sorensen also turned up dead hmm
interestingly the same day on which two
life insurance policies on him
overlapped how he died was apparently
now the interesting thing about his
death the first doctor that saw him like
that came to attend the the death was
like [ __ ] that's strychnine poisoning
right however mad Sorensen had been
under Gunder going treatment for a heart
condition I think he had an enlarged
heart or something like that so another
doctor said no it was just like a heart
attack he had some kind of you know he
had some kind of heart condition and
that's what killed him so I guess the
second doctor's opinion overrode the
first one so they didn't do an autopsy
because they thought I'm not suspicious
at all of course not of course it wasn't
suspicious and Belle Gunness even told
the doctors that she's like yeah I've
been giving him these like medicines
that I make like to make him feel better
for his heart condition you know so yeah
so apparently everyone bought that right
the day after Matt Sorenson was buried
the day after his funeral she walks in
and collects her insurance payment now
there was actually um an inquest ordered
into his death after that because
they're like okay well maybe it was
suspicious after all but I don't know if
they ever did anything about it they did
order an inquest but I don't know if it
ever took place like no records of it
survive there are records that say yes
they ordered an inquest but there's no
records of the inquest itself so they
don't know if they ever went through
with it they don't know if they exhumed
his body or anything like that now she
actually ended up from his death she
actually claiming his body back in those
days wouldn't help them at all though
technology that they had I see why they
didn't they didn't bother when they
couldn't tell who was poisoning him well
so she ended up getting about in those
in those days money
which was
1900 about $8,500 which in today's money
would be over 250 grand yeah so that's
how much she's going yeah from for Matt
Sorenson stuff
nothing buy a house easy and that's
exactly what she did in 1981 she bought
a big farm in LaPorte Indiana and
reportedly the boat and carriage houses
on this farm burned down shortly I
bought the she again like the heart for
this area you can't help serious gas she
can't help herself what are the what's
the likelihood of all this happening to
the same woman in the same lifetime
that's what I mean it's just well yeah
obviously
so now before she moved to the farm in
Indiana she kind of got back together
with this guy she knew whose wife had
just died and his name was Peter Gunness
now he was also originally from Norway
they got married in 1902 one week after
they got married Peter Gunness his
infant daughter died okay interesting
hey it's not funny
it's a baby yeah she was the baby was in
the house alone with Belle yeah I don't
know actually I'm the exact it said it
says uncertain causes so it was like
unknown she choked that baby out or
something sure her thing was mostly
poisoning or sometimes bludgeoning to
pee but you couldn't poison a baby in
one day true yeah I don't know what she
might have smothered it yeah she
smothered it seems like that's probably
the easiest easy thank you and doesn't
you know something like crib death yeah
but it doesn't if they had that back I
don't know if they did I may have had
another excuse that they could have used
you yeah well babies die well they did
back then that's what like that that's
why they couldn't prove she died of
consumption some weird [ __ ] like that
yeah one of those weird
dropsy or what's wrong
yeah so that was uh that was in April of
1902 now in December of 1902 Peter
Gunness the husband also died in a
quote/unquote tragic accident now listen
to this story this is the tragic
accident okay Bell says that Peter
Gunness was in the house and that his
slippers were next to the stove in the
kitchen and he was reaching for them and
then there was like a pot of brine that
was like boiling on the end it tipped
over and burned him and then and that
made like part of this big sausage
grinding machine that they had up on a
shelf above the snow fall down and hit
him in the head and crushed his skull no
she crushed his ass with that damn
machine that damned sausage [ __ ] but
they do some hot water on it that's what
she said happened yeah now even then it
seemed like like people around town were
like you know Peter Gunness he was a
butcher yeah he was very good at his job
like they're like he was like pretty
coordinated that seems like a really
improbable thing to happen it was like
super klutzy that's like some [ __ ] I
would do seriously she's yeah she's all
thumbs I know I can't help it it's
Jeanette but it's in her mind it's not
genetic it's because she worries about
it
well yeah it's put yourself in the
spotlight but yeah I'm a dork I'm a
klutz I can't help it
I'm gonna get her out of it but um yeah
so that's so even then like some people
that know him and stuff like that were
like really that sounds that doesn't
sound like something that would happen
it's like he's really not that klutzy
but you know at any rate no one really
has a story a dame would make up that it
does seem like like I said if you're
gonna kill if you're gonna bump off your
husband for the insurance money
I mean at least make it look like
something that could like like a manly
death like he was trying you know what I
mean yeah he was trying to like you know
barbeque some [ __ ] and he liked it
[ __ ] I fell down in a well make it
sound like some more the CIA has said
over and over and over again
the most plausible way to commit
homicide is to push somebody out of
window
see that's what I always thought to like
make it look like like cuz they can't
prove that it's hard to prove alright
unless somebody sees it and even then
you can still argue with it push
somebody out of so yeah there's no way
to prove it so you know perfect there's
cameras today it's not like it was back
then yeah for all you know you throw a
[ __ ] out a window and across the
street there's a camera pointed at you
there probably is they see your smile
and ass [ __ ] throw and subdueth at the
phone there's cameras today just have
pictures of you hammers now it's not the
same okay so Peter Gunness is dead in
this wildly improbable manner but
apparently the insurance company doesn't
think that's weird enough to not pay
because they do she got about three
thousand dollars in back then money
which is a over a hundred thousand
dollars in today money so like I said a
lot of the locals were just like yeah no
I don't think so
now the coroner did actually come
forward and say I think he got murdered
we need another jury we need to convene
we did do an inquest and all this other
stuff so there was some suspicion thrown
on her and there was also allegedly the
the adopted daughter Jenny Olsen who at
this point was 14 allegedly she told a
classmate and was overheard to say my
mama killed my papa
don't tell anyone I told oh [ __ ] now so
like I don't know if that's true or not
but allegedly someone overheard her
saying that to a friend of hers so
hearsay yes so they brought the kid
before the coroner's jury the kid said
no I never said that
so I don't know if she thought she was
gonna get killed too maybe her mom's
straighten that out real quick yeah um
so it happened that Belle Gunness at
this point she was actually brought
before the coroner's jury um but she
kind of pleaded her and she's like no it
was just an accident and all this other
stuff now she was pregnant at this point
but she didn't tell anybody that they're
not sure why because they said if she'd
you know she'd said she was pregnant she
probably would've got more sympathy but
it didn't matter
and in the end it didn't matter because
they still they didn't they couldn't
prove it so she actually got off with it
that time too now in 1903 she gave birth
to a little boy named Philip and then
the next thing that happened was this
was in 1906 nobody had seen Jenny Olsen
the adopted daughter around for quite a
while so people started asking about it
Belle's like oh she went away to Los
Angeles to this Lutheran College she
told some of the neighbors that she told
other neighbors that she went off to
some finishing school somewhere else you
can probably imagine where that little
girl ended up we will find out later on
she was not a neither one of those
places so between 1903 and 1906 from the
time that she had the baby boy Philip
Tucson the Jenny Olsen disappeared um
about 1907 then she she gave a job to
this guy named ray Lamphere he was her
farmhand now around the time that ray
started working on her farm she also
started she decided to expand her
horizons so what she started to do I
guess back in the day you could run
there was in the newspapers they had a
matrimonial column and ladies of means
could run advertisements in there saying
hey I want some guy with money to come
out and will join our fortunes
chi-ching kill another one this is Black
Widow yeah this yeah they do good the
black widow the lonely yes exactly so
one of the answer is she ran them in
several newspapers her ad said personal
comely widow who owns a large farm in
one of the finest districts in LaPorte
County Indiana desires to make the
acquaintance of a gentleman equally well
provided with view of joining fortunes
no replies by letter considered unless
sender is willing to follow answer with
personal visit try fleurs need not apply
yeah you trifler know trifle and
[ __ ] seriously now I have to
say at this point Belle Gunness there
were a lot of responses this was just
like now there's a lot of desperate
dudes out there I guess
Belle Gunness when she was young I don't
think I would call her a pretty woman
she was a handsome woman she was also a
big strappin woman she was six feet tall
yeah this is before they had the term
big fine okay they have big five back
then uh she was six feet tall about 200
pounds what they call a yes oh good good
German Germanic yes Germanic working
woman and by all accounts yeah she was a
big [ __ ] bad shoulder with your ass you
get out a lot yeah and by all accounts
she was easily as strong as a man it's
not stronger because a lot of her like
farmhands and stuff like that they said
they would bring her like these watch
that woman she would pick him right up
put him on her shoulders and carry him
like they didn't weigh anything right so
she was like a very very physically
imposing very very Oregon Trail chicks
yes she was a big big woman so she runs
this personal ad now they get she gets
like a whole bunch of responses now one
of the first ones she got was this guy
named John Moe he came from Minnesota
now he brought $1,000 with him in
old-timey money and he brought it so he
could pay off her mortgage so he could
pay he could prove like how much - Lexi
I'm wealthy I hope I'm not driving yeah
he's not trifling now the first red flag
that should have made him run away but
did not was that Belle Gunness
introduces him to the seven neighbors
and doesn't say oh this is a guy I'm
gonna marry or this is you know one of
my nan trifling personal a dancers she
said that he was her cousin so that
seemed a little weird but he didn't
apparently think so so he was only at
the farm for a few days and then
vanished off the face of the earth
damn then there was another guy named
George so they don't even find his body
uh we'll see she's okay she just took
his thousand dollars and knocked his ass
off didn't you yeah notice what she did
right many many many times
[Laughter]
about it kind of dumb I mean that that's
two-dimensional thinking when you think
about it although she got away with it
for a long time yeah well she's playing
other people for fools yeah but maybe
they were back then well they must have
must have been for you to rack up that
kind of body count before anybody said
hey wait a minute II thought about ya
know what you before everybody gets
together and is like hey I was gonna go
answer why are all these [ __ ]
whatever came back cuz hardly anybody it
was a different time only people came
from different states like I said you
would and you know if the guy was like
going to answer a personal and he
wouldn't necessarily say where he was
going or what anymore what her name was
or anything like that so the next guy
was named George Anderson he was from
Missouri and he was also a Norwegian
immigrant now he he came to the farm and
they were having dinner and Belle said
that he said that he would pay her
mortgage off like to prove just like the
other guy had if she agreed to marry him
so she lets him stay over at the farm
now the story goes that he woke up in
the middle of the night and saw Belle
Gunness standing over him like with a
candle in her pants she looked like all
she was just like a [ __ ] horror movie
right now this tipped him off thinking
about how she was gonna knock that ass
right this tipped him off now he flipped
out so she ran out of the room no heat
now the next day he skedaddle right so
he is the only person that they know of
that answered her ad that survived yeah
dude do is smart yes because apparently
the face she was making at him like
terrified him so much that he's just
like he left on the way out cuz she like
I said this was a big one and she was
very um like I said she was she was a
handsome woman but I could see how that
would be very scary six figures woman
like lurking yeah this is it this is a
time when the average man probably
weighed about 140 pounds too because she
seemed like she just carried him around
like it just flung him around like they
all do and I don't think guys for most
guys were not very big especially
according to the clothes and the
specification that were given they were
weedy little [ __ ] they didn't have
the new tree
or the physical fitness so if a woman
had genetically big bones she probably
whip your ass back then
yeah and like I said I'm sure she yeah
she killed and like I said her um
according to many people that worked on
her farm you know at this stage
she starts ordering these big trunks
like from the shops in town and so the
guy that drug drove the thing that
brought them he said Belle would come
out to the you know to the carriage she
would just pull the trunk off the
carriage sling it up on her shoulders
and just he said it carried it she said
he said that um said it it looked like
it just weighed nothing like a
marshmallow it's like like it weighed
nothing now there were also reports from
this time that many neighbors reported
that she was often seen in the middle of
the night digging in her hog pen so at
the time good place to hide bodies
nobody wants to dig up a [ __ ] the
next guy was an older guy he was a widow
work
his name was Olay buds burg and he was
from Wisconsin um the last time anybody
saw his ass was at the Laporte Savings
Bank in april of nineteen withdraw that
money withdrawing yeah several thousand
dollars and signing over a deed I saw
that coming
yes so now at this he had two sons now
they didn't know that that's where the
father had gone but when they finally
figured it out later on they wrote to
her and were like hey did my dad come
like an answer where you add she's like
no I don't know why yeah she's like I
never saw so then over the next few
months several more men replied to her
ad and never returned home there was a
guy in December of 1907 whose name was
Andrew Helga line and he was from South
Dakota and he wrote her a letter and
they they actually have a lot of the
letter still survived that they wrote
back and forth to each other now listen
to this [ __ ] this is a letter that Belle
wrote to him
in January of 1908 listen to how she was
how thick she lays this [ __ ] on man oh
it's gonna be I love you by the way
bring me your money and we'll join she
actually she didn't say that exactly
okay she says to the dearest friend in
the world no woman in the world is
happier than I am I know that you were
now to come to me and be my own I can
tell from your letters that you were the
man I want it does not take long it does
not take one long to tell when to like a
person and you I like better than anyone
in the world I know think how we will
enjoy each other's company you the
sweetest man in the whole world we will
be all alone with each other can you
conceive of anything nicer oh yeah I
think of you constantly when I hear your
name mentioned and this is when one of
the dear children speaks of you or I
hear myself humming it with the words of
an old love song it's a beautiful music
to my ears my heart beats in wild
rapture for you my Andrew I love you
come prepared to stay forever oh [ __ ]
that's like some [ __ ] from the [ __ ]
Disney haunted house isn't that creepy
Oh like that last sentence is like I
read that and like all the hairs no
creepy and she's telling that dude what
he wanted to hear yeah like an apparel
of being you together alone forever
you're the night oh [ __ ] he's thinking
about getting laid she think about
killing your ass yes it worked he came
here he came don't mention to bring me
your money though no okay maybe spend on
other letters go to the bank real quick
before they have that withdraw that [ __ ]
put it in my account we'll have a joint
account yeah because when he came after
that letter cuz like I said he was just
like oh this is this is a woman for me
I'm going so he turns up there uh you
know later that month with him he has a
check for $2,900 which is all his
savings he had taken all of his savings
out of his bank and then they he so he
gets their know if
few days after he got there he was seen
alive again at the Bank Gunness was with
him and they were in LaPorte Indiana
they deposited his check
couple days after that he disappeared
poof I wonder where he went well yeah I
think that pigsty buried underneath that
pig that's but yeah so Belle Gunness
turns up at the bank a couple more times
putting in little deposits five hundred
dollars here's seven hundred dollars
there now at this stage no I
isn't the aren't the people at the
banking kind of curious what the [ __ ]
going on evidently not maybe they kind
of have a they kind of have this code
don't tell ya what they're like well
this money is entering our bank okay
it's not on us to figure out where is
all this you know where this is coming
from it's just Bank money yeah and I
feel like they might be less likely to
question a woman also maybe I I would
think that they would know that hey this
these guys are depositing all this money
in this woman's account and we're never
seeing these guys again yeah well then
maybe I don't know maybe they just
didn't notice those tellers would know I
think what well I think what it was is
that the bank manager Bank yeah the bank
Bakke owners like well hey that's a
thousand dollars man yeah it's like shut
up
let it ride yes it's not on us we don't
want to stop that money true yeah that's
not our that's not our we're not in that
line of work
right that's law enforcement all right
that's probably exactly what they said
yeah yeah it's like hey it's not our job
to wonder what the hell's going on yeah
so around this time she's been starting
to have problems with her little
farmhand ray Lamphere now apparently and
this is bizarre ray Lamphere
apparently has fallen madly in love with
Belle Gunness during this time and he's
starting to get really annoyed at all
these other dudes showing up now as far
as I know ray Lamphere knew that she was
killing all these dudes because he would
help I don't think he helped killing
anybody but he did help
burying them and like
like that she had heart I'm pretty sure
but he's starting to get really bothered
by like all these other dudes showing up
cuz he's apparently in love with her so
he starts because she's the real boy
he's the real boyfriend
well I don't know I don't I don't know
if she was like involved how much you
want to bet maybe if there's an
arrangement he's the real boyfriend yeah
it might have been so he's starting to
get annoyed he's like I don't like all
these other men coming around and I
don't like this involve habla so bellas
just kind of like okay well you're gonna
be a problem for me so actually she just
fired him hmm
so so II just thought he was the real
boyfriend right so he yeah so he started
like making scenes and stuff so she got
rid of him in February of nineteen oh
eight now then to cover her own ass she
immediately like the day after she fired
him she shows up at the courthouse and
she goes I'm having all this problems
with my former farmhand
he was like harassing me he's
threatening to kill my family and burn
my farm down and he keeps coming around
and it's like can you guys you know do
something about it or whatever loosen
she's gonna get rid of him right so
she's like he's a menace to society she
told them so they actually believed her
and they held a sanity hearing um but
they found that he was saying and fine
and they let him go so then a couple
days after that Belle Gunness comes back
to tell the sheriff that oh that Ray guy
he's been around here and he's arguing
and I can't get rid of him and you need
to do something about it because he's
threatening my family and all this other
stuff and he got arrested for
trespassing so evidently even after he
kept getting out of jail he kept coming
back like surfer so apparently he really
didn't love her for whatever reason
because he could have probably just told
the authorities I would ask a hey she's
a murderer right but he never seemed to
do that
didn't leave no he didn't leave he kept
coming back um now he did kind of make
some threats toward her he did allegedly
tell another farmer or implied that they
had killed and
helga line so everything was the
situation though maybe she told him a
different story that's what I mean I'm
not entirely sure how completely he's
gonna marry that guy and then he did
this and that to me and I had to kill
him in self-defense it might have been
that it might have been oh he turned up
and he was the [ __ ] just like the
other ones do something about that right
you know who knows yeah but so it was a
different time yeah so you know like I
said she didn't really seem to be able
to persuade him to do it himself
I don't know if he I don't think he
killed any of the people I think she did
all of that but he may have helped her
get rid of the bodies but like you said
she might have given her given him like
some kind of line about right you know
they try to take my money or they tried
to rape me or something like that it's
like who knows he was a bad man yeah so
at this stage now Andrew helga line had
been missing for quite a while now he
and her brother um and he the brother
was actually like okay and the brother
knew where Andrew hell dad had gone so
he writes to Bell ganas and he's like
where's my brother he was coming out to
see you and she says yeah he came here
but he left maybe he went back to Norway
to visit family you know how would the
hell would I know I don't know where he
went
so then the brother writes back and he's
like I do not believe you um I don't
think he would get an or without telling
us where he was going
I think he's still there and that cuz
that's the last place that we heard from
him so Belle Gunness drops her nuts and
says okay come on out bonus head well
metaphor oh man she dropped her
metaphorical no and she basically says
to the brother come on out here and
search for him but guess what searching
for a missing person around the farm
that's gonna cost you because it costs a
lot of money to look for missing persons
to bring some money out here and I'll
let you look for him that's what she
said so he actually did come out to look
for the brother now at this stage she is
told like everybody about this Ray
Lamphere guy her former her former
farmhand
she told the lawyer she told the sheriff
she'll sue so everybody she's like
setting this up to make him the fall guy
essentially
think is what she was doing because she
said oh he's gonna kill me he's gonna
kill my children whatever and she
specifically said he's gonna kill us and
burn the farm down
she told several people that including
her lawyer so she said I want to make
out a will in case he really does it so
her lawyer drew up a will she made it
out and everything like that she left
the entire state to her kids then she
leaves the lawyers offices then she goes
to her bank and evidently she takes out
most of her money again no one thought
that was strange now at this point she
had hired another farmhand his name was
Joe Maxon after ray Lamphere had left in
April late April of 1908 he's been
living in the house he wakes up and the
house is on fire and so his smell smoke
a newsroom be opens the door of his room
and it's just it's just flames so he's
just in his underwear he jumps out the
[ __ ] second-floor window and just
barely escapes with his life I mean the
whole house is just like it's [ __ ]
torched it's been a pretty big house
yeah it was it's you know there's
nothing left of it now obviously because
it burnt to the ground um it was it was
a big plot of land but yeah so he goes
out he goes to the town and get help but
by the time you know the fire marshals
get there there's just nothing left now
interestingly in the ruins of Belle
Gunness farm they find four bodies three
of them are children
she had three surviving children and
they're assuming that that's who those
three bodies were they were her little
kids they also found the body of a woman
which at first they assumed was Belle
Gunness but they couldn't tell because
the body didn't have a head and they
never did find it also the coroner was
kind of like and all the neighbors were
kind of like I don't think that's Belle
gun is because the coroner said this
body is a female body but this woman was
probably only about five foot three and
couldn't have weighed any more than 150
pounds as I said Belle Gunness was at
least six feet tall and weighed at least
200 pounds she was a very very large
woman so a lot of people said this could
not be her skeleton there any nice and
women yeah we'll get to that but yes so
there was kind of and then the her
dentist comes forward and says well we
can't find the head but if you can find
I did a bunch of dental work on her that
I would recognize so if you can find the
teeth cuz I think she were like a
partial plate or like some kind of crown
or something like that it wasn't
entirely clear that like if you can find
that in the ruins and maybe I can make a
positive identification coincidentally
somebody found a set of teeth in the
ruins they never defined a head but they
found a set of teeth and the dentist was
like yeah that's totally Belle Gunness
his teeth so that must be who that is
except nobody buys it because they're
like there's no way that could have been
her because they're like this was a
small woman so but because the dentist
identified you take your teeth out
though because they came out it was like
dentures okay like dentures yeah do her
dentures in there yeah so like I said
there was controversy but since the
dentist said things like okay well I
guess that was Belle and her three kids
and they burned to death and Ray
Lamphere must have burned the house down
just like she said that he was going to
now fire can totally destroy bone but it
would have to be really hot they just
think for a long time but they're
sitting there saying weirdly yeah it's
like but the rest of the bodies looked
like they would have looked they were
the size and shape of the children that
they thought that they were so they just
thought it was berries and they thought
it was strange because they're like
where's the head you know they found all
the other heads it's like why did we
just find no head on this body that
seems a little weird
so they actually um so they went to
arrest Lela ray Lamphere because she had
told them hey he said he was gonna burn
my house down and lo and behold the
house burned down so they arrest said
that because she was gonna exactly
exactly that's right that she was
setting it up yeah so he gets arrested
now he really didn't help his case all
that much they said hey the house burned
down and he said oh did they get out
okay did Belle Gunness and the kids get
out okay even
or they really said what had happened
and then he's like no no that wasn't me
but then another guy like a neighbor
said that he had seen ray Lamphere
running away from the site right so and
he was apparently pretty credible he
could have been paid off it could have
been but we'll I'll get to that like how
this could have been had this could have
been happening okay okay so ray Lea beer
is arrested for arson and murder okay on
the word of this person and like I said
the threats beforehand now at this stage
um the brother of Andrew Helga Lyon
whose name was Ashley Helga Lyon he
shows up in town and he says look I
think that bail gun has killed my
brother
so then Joe Maxon who was the hired hand
that Bell had hired after she fired ray
Lamphere he comes fort he says yeah you
know um she asked me to bring like all
these wheelbarrows of dirt and fill in
all these mysterious depressions in the
Hogben she wanted all the the hog pen
she wanted all the ground-level
and I thought that was a little funny
but you know I'm I worked there so I did
it anyway
so the cops are like maybe we should dig
yeah
so they start digging in the hog pen
first body they found Jenny Olsen the
adopted daughter who was 14 years old
she had vanished on December 1906 she
was the first one they found in that
they identified then they found two more
bodies that were very small children
they I don't think those two were ever
identified they might have been hers or
they might have been somebody's that she
brought along with somebody brought
along with her I want to say something
real quick that's been well fed hogs
because hogs can smell like it crazy
yeah it's it's a smell well they're
hungry they'd have smelled those bodies
hear them there are some sources that
claim that some of the bodies she did
cut them up and feed them to the heart
okay all right so yeah because they
don't know there are more people missing
that they think answered her ad than
bodies that they thought oh they did
found out find a lot then they found the
body of Andrew Helga line some reports
say that his brother was actually the
one that found the body they actually
have a photograph of it I'll put it in
the video it's pretty gross but yeah
they found his body
they kept digging and they kept coming
across more now the ones that they
identified um oleh buds burg who was one
of the guys that answered her ad he
disappeared in May of 1907 a guy named
Thomas Lin beau who she had hired to
work on the farm they found his body
there was another guy named Henry ger
holt and he was another one that had
answered the ad and he had brought like
$1,500 with him they found a watch that
they know belonged to him so they knew
it was him several other guys that had
answered the ad they also found his
bodies then like they were asking around
like as news got out of all these bodies
they were finding they were getting
people that reported like families that
were like hey you know our you know
uncle our dad or whatever like went out
there to meet that woman so they found a
bunch of other bodies that they're not
sure who they are but they think some of
them possible victims might have been
some other guys that guy named William
Minnie a guy named Herman Konitz or you
know there's just several others there's
a huge huge list I think if you get a
wikipedia or you I don't actually I
don't know if they have all the victims
on Wikipedia I found him somewhere else
I might might be on murder pedia that
actually has a better a better write up
yeah there was just tons and tons and
tons of people and they'll say they
found like rings and things belonging to
people so as I said they're not sure
entirely how many people she killed
lowest estimate 25 highest estimate
about 40 but might have been more than
that they did find some things and like
I said ray Lamphere said that she maybe
had cut up some of the people and fed
them to the Hogs so they don't really
know so ray Lamphere stands trial in May
of 1908 for the murder charge and the
arson charge there were at the trial
there were kind of allegations that the
dentist who had you know made the
coroner say yeah that was Belle Gunness
his body in the fire that he had planted
that denture hmm right or that he had
been the one the founder or whatever so
there was some allegation that that
happened
now also later on because Ray Lamphere
they they actually did get him on the
arson
charge but not on the murder charge but
he actually came forward later and
according to a reverend who he allegedly
confessed to he actually said what Belle
Gunness had done it's like one he said
she's still alive that wasn't her in the
fire she just took off and changed her
name or whatever um he says I didn't
murder anybody but I did help her bury a
lot of the victims he said what she
would do is like the guy would come with
the money and everything and she would
take him and they would deposit the
money she would then make him a big
dinner she would put she would either
put like sleeping pills or she would put
poison in the coffee and then when the
guy fell asleep she would bash in his
head with like a cleaver is what she
would do sometimes they're like also
sometimes she would wait for the guy to
go to bed and then would go in there and
chloroform him um they said that she was
actually like I said she was a big
strong woman so she a lot of times would
just they would chloroform then she'd
just sling him over her shoulder take
him out to the hog pen she would she
would usually take them down and she
would dissect them she's like he he was
she was very good at that because her
Peter Gunness had been a butcher and
evidently taught her how to do that so
she would cut she would cut up the
bodies and bury them in the hog vent
where she would feed them to the Hogs
they said sometimes she would put the
bodies into the Hogs scalding VAT and
covered them with quicklime so as I said
they have no idea how many people she
actually killed because he's like there
was a lot um I think I believe he said
by his count it was 42 men Dan um but
there may be more and I don't think he
was counting all the kids that she
killed because I thought she killed a
bunch of children too including
most of her own no Psychopaths yeah now
ray Lamphere also said he said the woman
that was found in the fire with no head
they said this woman was a woman that I
don't know if he knew what her name was
but he said Bell actually got her to
come from Chicago to work as a
housekeeper on her farm and
this was only like a few days before she
was planning on burning the place down
and getting the [ __ ] out of there so she
was planning this she had this whole
scheme worked out so that was her out so
yeah she had somebody I mean you'd think
she would've been smart enough to like
find a body that was like her size but
you know I guess beggars can't be
choosers
right so he's like this so this woman
came thinking she had a job at which
point Bell drugged her bashed her in the
head and then cut her head off said took
the head uh weighted it down and threw
it into a really deep swamp and then she
evidently chloroformed her own children
smothered them and then left them in
their beds then left the house on fire
and got the [ __ ] out of Dodge damn she
said she did actually dress the body and
her clothes she took out her dentures
and left them next to things so be
identified as her but she didn't want
the head there and then she got the hell
out of there now over the ensuing years
now late ray Lamphere said by his
account like I said that she had killed
at least 42 men she thinks that over the
course of her career let's call it that
she had made over a quarter million
dollars in old-timey money from all her
said which is a which is almost 7
million dollars in today's money so she
cashed in she knew she was doing and she
got away with it they never caught her
and how much of the money did she escape
with um I'm not entirely sure might have
been all of that
well most are a large portion of it so
evidently for many ensuing us crime did
pay her it did sadly enough although she
narrowly escaped yeah but she did escape
yeah they never found her now evidently
she was spotted many times over the
ensuing years some people claim they saw
in San Francisco some people said they
saw in Los Angeles some people said they
saw her in New York
in 1931 someone reported seeing her
living in Mississippi yeah um she
apparently a good place to run yeah she
actually owned like a great deal of land
there and was kind of well known but she
had changed her name so that was so she
kind of thinking ahead she did symbolize
yeah plan for the farm the farm was a
scene of the crime yeah she was gonna
bring a bunch of guys there murder him
steal their money and then run from
there honestly I don't think she would
have done that if Ray Lamphere hadn't
started acting up and she thought that
he was gonna make trouble for her so I
think when that [ __ ] started happening
like when he started making a scene and
she thought oh he's gonna narc on me
then she thought okay maybe I need to
get the [ __ ] I couldn't run that scam
forever and that location exactly I
don't have to move but maybe the fact of
him doing that like just kind of speeded
along like what she was gonna do I feel
like because that you know she had been
doing it for years and years and no one
had really caught on
every time you move you're starting
fresh with that big bundle of money yes
there was no way to trace you yeah so
yeah now interestingly the same year
that she was reported living in
Mississippi in Los Angeles
that same year 1931 a woman named Esther
Carlson was arrested for poisoning a
dude for money hmm
now a couple people who saw photographs
of her in the paper swore that that was
Belle Gunness but they could never prove
that it not only was did they say
exactly where in Mississippi uh I don't
think so with that kind of money you
could have owned a significant part yeah
at that time yeah you probably could
have and reportedly she did she had like
a very large thing so evidently they
buried this body next to her first
husband in an Illinois Cemetery the body
that they found in the fire which is
probably not her now in 2007 they wanted
to do a DNA analysis cuz they wanted to
decide once a fraud was that really her
um they actually were trying to get DNA
from some stuff that had been at the
farm that had survived like that they
hoped would still have DNA on it likely
no letters that she had licked or
whatever but they couldn't get enough
DNA to make a profile that they could
match to this they know that they know
where the location of this farm is to
this day yeah yeah well it's funny
because even after that half like I said
LaPorte Indiana I believe they're still
like a big sign they
everything people still go there's
obviously the farms gone but even at the
time like after it happened it became a
huge tourist attraction okay there's
pictures of like people there's like all
these old-timey cars like a long side of
the road like to come see the murder
farm you know what I mean you know there
but they were like back then yeah like
that now I know but I'm just like it's
like you tend to think of people back
then oh they were so they had decorum
and said no they didn't they did the
same kind of [ __ ] we do nowadays it's
like let's go see where all these people
got murdered English I'm a [ __ ] PT
Barnum yeah same kind of thing so as I
said things worked out kinda better for
her though I mean the Hart brothers they
both got their heads chopped off and
like put up on [ __ ] spikes and
everything being like you know like I
said a warning to the others Belle
Gunness made it out of there she got
away with that [ __ ] she killed everybody
and everybody with it with all the money
and evident I'm a novice Lee she's dead
now but I don't think she ever got
caught for that [ __ ] cuz I don't think
that was her and she had enough money to
change her name start a new life then
and that's probably apparently what she
did yeah so yeah like you said crime did
pay in her case but yeah so well I
guarantee she had all kinds of mental
[ __ ] problems over doing that well
well you would hope your own kids even
you know yeah but like I said maybe
maybe she just had a thing like the harp
she was just like this practical kind of
like might have been just a total
sociopath total psycho
no bad no feelings towards other people
she must have been yeah she was like I
said she doesn't and again I'm not
saying that female serial killers of
this type I'm not saying they don't
enjoy the killing I'm just saying that
she didn't seem to like take a lot of
pleasure and it's just too like she she
usually just use my way from them yes
she just poisoned them or bashed him in
the head and just cut him up in bed with
hogs just you know what I mean it wasn't
like she was like getting off on it like
a sexual she was just getting them out
of the way because she wanted their
money and she didn't want I'm sure there
was a rush of power though probably
getting all this money for nothing
basically yeah well you know big old
birds walked by
did they really oh my god there's huge
Santa usually all right outside the
windows are five feet tall they might
knock in a minute they call a person
walking by the way we call them the
dinosaur birds if you feed them one time
which technically you're not they never
forget you they're very loud but Adam
was they know
once he gave him like some bread or some
girl and they all know me they show up
Nick and then they want me to feed their
children yeah they should yeah but they
should put their babies the show they
say hey feed them you fed us one time
and actually if you don't come out cuz
they have they have a very loud if
you're not from for if you not got a
window they'll knock on your window or
your door and they know where you are
yeah I've had them come to like we have
a door like right back here by behind my
office and I've had them coming like
sump on the door with their beaks when
they knocked on our bedroom window with
their beaks they know you're in there
and they'll pass their children forward
and go feed them yeah they're really
weird birds they're very smart yeah
there and they're like as tall as me
yeah they're like a little they're
protected bird yeah legally you're not
supposed to feed her but well yeah yeah
like I said because they're good I want
their kind of a nuisance to do theirs
they're very noisy like their their call
is very very nice and they will try to
come in the house they will yeah yeah
yeah they're not they don't scare people
right I give a single [ __ ] nope they
will walk right it bright in your house
if you let them be like hey you got
anything in here yeah and then they'll
probably [ __ ] pick you up you know
beat up your cats yeah cats either no
they're not scared of anything
like I said they look like [ __ ]
velociraptors or some [ __ ] yeah all
right so let's wrap this up a really
long time this is kind of a fun show
though I was holy crap I can barely talk
I know we got to go out tonight
I haven't even got through my first one
we gotta go out tonight well that's on
you I had a small one cuz I knew we'd be
going out tonight true we haven't been
out on a Saturday night in a really long
time so we're going right I'm excited
about it but that's why I'm that's why
I'm keeping it small okay you already
had two big jars yeah you can go take a
nap it'll be alright yeah alright so
that'll do it for this old timey
true-crime episode hope you guys enjoyed
it remember if you liked the show to
like share subscribe and all your social
media and share with all your friends
and neighbors and acquaintances and
feeding people you don't like I don't
give a [ __ ] everybody and if you'd like
to financially support the show you can
go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcasts or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com you keep
moving and you're making the point I
wanted like you're making the autofit
okay
he's messing up my honor funny oh he's
get all butter anyway as I was saying go
to our blog which is 13 lakh podcast at
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give a one-time donation if you
would like to do that please check out
our azazel store at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock hopefully all the shirts are
visible now hmm if that works out okay I
can't believe I took me this long to
figure the [ __ ] out why nobody could see
[ __ ] also check out our last movie
review which was reanimated we will
probably be doing more classic 80s
horror over the next few weeks because
of our shutter subscription they have a
really good selection of classic 80s
horror on there so we're gonna be doing
a lot of those and I think that'll do it
for episode 112 we will see you next
time bye
[Music]
The Ballad of Belle Gunness begins after
the flames Samton to the ashes for her
family's remains three children and her
body all had been played but fails was
found to be headless
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]